un couple nos relations au couple ça
révèle de la vie privée je crois pas le
sahara knafo cherche à s'afficher depuis
le début de cette pré campagne s'arrête
à fosses et une d'ailleurs tous les
articles 10 et une conseillère de
l'ombre elle ne cherche pas à se mettre
en avant je vous crois que ça regarde
personne c'est elle est enceinte ou pas
et des rolls et ne même pas le sujet le
sujet c'est de savoir si en fait on va
pouvoir faire une campagne
présidentielle avec des idées politiques
essayent donc il va
et vous si on m'appelle thomas
présidentielle sur des people de sarah
knafo et avec des mots voici enfin une
campagne sur des idées politiques pour
l'instant la presse a décidé de servir
en fait tout le talent de sa vie privée
parenthèse là ça me rend fou ça c'est si
cc66 et molas et dégringole ça
dégringole pas comme moi je la vois je
sais très bien qu'il a eue le dit eric
zemmour on sait très bien qu'on a des
idées complètement opposées il va venir
me voir le 16 décembre ici puisque on
fera une émission il a accepté de faire
l'émission avec moi mes exams homme si
dégringole il à 15% vous rendez pas
compte c'est énorme mais je voudrais des
comptes que ces 15% quand j'entends des
gens dire eric zemmour y dégringole mais
qu'est ce que c'est que cette ineptie
pas de bêtises il a perdu trois points
il à 15% qu'il abandonne à 15% s'il
avait été déjà 8 on aurait dit que
c'était un miracle il a 15
et la darse non mais c'est vrai ça ne
pose un final où soit 15 arrêté mais ma
douce énorme il ya plein de candidats
qui rêvent vrai bien sûr il est super
long et vous le savez je suis pas du
tout eric zemmour et le c'est rythmé
ondes et on discute avec kirikou avec
stanislas même si on est opposé voilà
voilà je suis là mais il faut arrêter de
dire à 15% il dégringole c'est comme si
vous disiez à 10 millions de
téléspectateurs miss france baisse non
l'orientation se tasse oui oui oui bah
c'est beau aussi stanislas et merci nous
on est au moins sept personnes j'ai vu
information hier on me l'a donnée j'ai
trouvé ça ridicule d'ailleurs j'ai même
pas cherché à savoir auprès ni sarah que
la phonie d'eric zemmour si c'était vrai
ou faux nou lé dans le camp zemmour la
seule réaction qu'on a eu c'est on ne
lâchera ni eric zemmour ni sarah knafo
danse on est là pour mener une campagne
présidentielle et pour la gagner on
absolument pas là pour se préoccuper de
leur vie privée sartre n'affole
fontrailles dans l'ombre de dalian
cherche pas à s'afficher il faut que
toute personne qui est arrivé à côtoyer
commencer un trait caractéristique c'est
une personne tu veux pour l'instant
rester de son côté et faire ce qu'on
travaille dans l'ombre comment ça réagit
dans le club et moi bah écoutez pas
surpris par le niveau de la presse
people en france on a habitué à ce genre
de l'adf je suis sur le plateau c'était
pour parler des du magnifique papier de
public avec ses légendes et extrêmement
fine des bons départs on n'est pas
surpris par la presse et les grains
gaulin
[Musique]
sais pas s'ils sont à 10 millions de
ventes mais c'est pas qu'ils vont encore
battre un record avec la une de closer
nous on n'est pas surpris on est on
s'attend à ce genre d' attaque et en
plus on sait ça a surpris beaucoup de
monde à même la presse people elle nous
l'a dit hier me regarde avec nous elles
y seraient pas allés est-ce que closer a
eu raison de sourire c'est là qu'ils
disent que c'est un coup extraordinaire
que puzzle agent il encore tenir
beaucoup de raisons après après un camp
hollande il faut encore un coup énorme
matthew d'abord au delà du coup
médiatique pour eux tant mieux vendre en
est très bien mais moi je vais aller au
delà de ça c'est que eric zemmour quand
j'écoute un petit peu il passe son temps
à nous vendre les valeurs familiales
judéo chrétienne un homme une femme
peut-être même un homme qui qui qui
domine un peu la femme des enfants pas
de pm a pas de gp a pas d'homosexuels
bref la famille parfaite écrite comme il
ya un siècle et donc on découvre que ce
monsieur qui nous vend ces valeurs là
qu'on aime ou qu'on aime pas mais pour
qui on pourrait voter
bah ce monsieur là lui en fait ces
valeurs à lui c'est une femme qui trompe
une maîtresse et qui met enceinte c'est
sa vie mais ça m'intéresse comme de
savoir que celui qui nous vend toutes
les valeurs de la famille fait l'
inverse mais ça va être quoi sur le
reste de sa campagne donc je trouve que
ce magazine là aujourd'hui people
ribardon a fait de l'information comme
souvent ils le font parfois a fait de
l'information alors c'est dégueulasse
d'un point de vue personnel mais c'est
pas sa vie mais moi je découvre un
zemmour qui ne vit pas du tout l'avis
qui vient nous vendre sur les plateaux
de télé mais
l'espoir dont battue mais je suis pas du
tout d'accord à quel moment tu sais si
c'est eric zemmour khamis arna fois en
sainteté tu es dans le lit avec es9 3e
avant elle n'a pas eu notre relation lui
sait
comment closer ainsi que ce sera ta
faute en soi comment commencer comment
claude rich aurait su que s'arracheront
foot enceinte mais c'est pas le sujet
alors c'est normal et c'est koné c'est
là la rumeur moi j'en avais jamais
entendu parler non me connaissent et
comment un an manon à jour une faille
pas d'intérêt qui doit leur dirai tout à
l'aube avec plaisir vous dirai tout à
l'heure quand on dort à leur égard
rochette de closer a lancé la même
version que la mienne parce que j'ai eu
quelques infos sur cette affaire voilà
donc c'est gris peut-être qu il le dira
lui oui ce qui est intéressant dans la
remise ont eu raison pas bien sûr qu'ils
ont eu raison moi je suis c'est un fait
politique majeur mais reçoit donc qu'ils
ont eu raison et ce qui est intéressant
dans l'assignation qu'ils ont fait pour
obtenir l'interdiction qu'ils n'ont pas
obtenu c'est qu'ils n'ont pas démenti
les faits ils n'ont pas dit c'est faux
ça c'est très intéressant déjà parce
qu'ils auraient pu lire c'est une fausse
information
et là peut-être que la chambre
correctionnelle qui étudiait aurait
interdit mais ils n'ont pas dit c'est
faux ils ont dit on veut retirer le
magazine des kiosques et ils ont été
retoqués parce qu'ils n'ont pas pu
prouver ce qu'il y avait dans le
magazine le magazine a astucieusement
caché jusqu'à la fin comme je suis pas
d'accord avec mathieu éric zemmour il a
toujours été très clair sur sa vision
des femmes d'ailleurs rendant dans ses
livres et je trouve que cette couverture
comme celle de paris match bizarrement
il humanise eric zemmour ce qu'on a
toujours l'habitude de le voir très
froid sur les plateaux avoir des propos
très durs là on le voit mine de rien
sourit ans dans un parc en amoureux donc
je pense que même si ça doit l'exaspérer
salut profite ensuite oui closer est
dans son droit eric zemmour il a atteint
un tel niveau de notoriété aujourd'hui
qui doit s'attendre malheureusement à ce
que ce genre d'info sorte closer ils
font leur boulot et voilà comme pour
françois hollande bon c'est c'est triste
mais c'est comme ça on va s'intéresser à
sa vie privée et puis vraiment si vous
voulez pas qu'on le filme pour le
prennent en photo extraite d'un faux il
faut pas se balader avec elle en ce
moment il est scrutée de partout eric
zemmour c'est injuste mais c'est comme
ça il ne vit plus avec sa femme en plus
le droit de parler
il est évidemment d'accord avec mathieu
avec gilles alors moi je réseaux eux
déplorent la pipolisation de la vie de
la vie politique en général mais là
pardon c'est un acte politique ça arrête
de faire un emprunt c'est un acte
politique il s'était d'abord c'est une
très bonne nouvelle un enfant qui va
naître au sérieux la chaussure ça ce
serait quand même une très bonne
nouvelle et est en fait non c'est vous
serez peut-être la barre elle
dit faites ce que je dis surtout fait
que je martèle sur les bateaux à la fête
parce que je suis effectivement je
trouve que c'est un acte politique d'en
montrer sa famille je sens que pardon
mais elle est quand même très très en
avant s'est jamais mis en avant de son
plein gré de
l'atelier sur ça c'est vraiment pour toi
elle travaille avec lui c'est normal
qu'elles soient partagées comme ça que
c'est hier sur ce point là c'est comme
si moi j'étais avec matthieu delormeau
ne suis pas enceinte et pourtant il se
met pas en avant s'est vu conseiller
avec les avant premières
balles et louis-joseph allait dans le
mur avec oui merci
mais ça oui là je vous confirme alors le
coup sakina faux et ça faut le dire
aussi à aucun moment elle de son propre
chef de cela en avant et d'ailleurs ça
l'info des mises en avant par les médias
que pour faire du plagiat de montréal
mais pour ses qualité de conseillère
pour sa stratégie a demandé où ces
réactions ont la tabasse sur sa vie
privée la plaine
farman à la
droite a bâti la raison la une de paris
match prouve çà et là aussi on a dit
qu'elle est possible que ça fera pas
preuve tu ce calendrier trois magazines
enfin il savait très bien que c'est une
correction à annaba oui mais on peut la
présenter autrement que sur le handicap
et brillante qu'elle a fait des études
alors l'avion une bande originale pour
coiffer la brillante zemmouri closer le
monde paris match c'est pour dire qu'en
gros c'est une femme et on ne fait que
peopolisé sa vie au travail du chemin
grimandi calais
jean pellet d'albi d'apprendre à faire
l'entraîneur jean madar je représente un
rédacteur en chef de closer qui a
beaucoup plus de choses à dire que vous
eh oui non non non aux cibles
familiales qu'il pousse à l'ehpad
marques de dents ça c'est sûr mais je
veux dire sarkozy a fait la même chose
tout frêche lui il passait de cécilia
cara de sa faute
ya rien à voir les volants qui n'a pas
passé des bleus on dilapide à ilaria
fait la justice mais manger des
croissants elle voulait bouffer
tous changer les femmes entre son fils
et leur vie privée ce sont des sous
policiers pourquoi c'est le médecin
volant de la même chose ce sont des
hommes ce sont des femmes cesser leur
l'emporter